Speaker 1: So there are many people who have
been hoping for waiting for praying for even
the demise of Joe Biden, and they are really
going to have to keep waiting, quite frankly,
at least for now, as Joe Biden's approval
rating has jumped to 63 percent, up two points
from late March.
This is not about cheerleading or praising
when there is nothing to praise, but it is
about understanding why Joe Biden's approval
rating is up again, but also importantly,
the areas where it's not because they actually
are cause for concern and show that the Republican
strategy has actually worked where they have
applied it.
And we're going to get to all of that.
But the data is that a new poll from the Associated
Press and NORC now has Joe Biden at 63 percent
approval, overall, 96 percent approval among
Democrats.
Trump would often tout 96 percent approval
from Republicans.
We could never find that data.
Joe Biden really has 96 percent approval from
Democrats.
AP NORC poll, 62 percent approval from independents
and yes, a paltry 23 percent approval among
Republicans.
But that is dramatically higher than Democratic
approval of Trump threw out Donald Trump's
presidency.
These are notable Republican approval numbers
for how how high they are, even at 23 percent.
And overall, this puts Joe Biden at 63 percent
approval.
Now, in this poll, the number of Americans
who are optimistic about the country's direction
is up to 54 percent.
We had a different poll yesterday which had
that number at 40 percent, up from 20 percent.
This poll asked the question a little differently.
And has Joe has the country at 54 percent
thinking we are moving in the right direction.
This is the highest of any AP poll dating
back to the beginning of Donald Trump's presidency.
In other words, the country is more optimistic
today than at any time during the Trump presidency.
What is pushing Joe Biden's approval rating
up?
The issues are handling of the covid pandemic.
Health care and the economy, according to
this very same poll, some of this is logical,
some of it is more notable.
For example, Democrats tend not to poll as
well on the economy, despite the fact that
the economy by every indicator does better
when a Democrat is in the White House rather
than a Republican.
That's interesting, 71 percent of Americans
approve of Joe Biden's handling of the pandemic.
And we are getting closer and closer to ending
the pandemic.
I'm going to have the latest numbers for you.
Probably tomorrow, maybe Thursday.
The last week has seen even faster declines
in cases, even faster declines in deaths.
Fortunately, an uptick in vaccination.
And we will get to that a little bit later
in the week.
Even 47 percent of Republicans approve of
Joe Biden's handling of the pandemic.
57 percent of Americans approve of Joe Biden's
handling of the economy.
62 percent approve of Joe Biden's handling
of health care so far, which has been mostly
prioritizing the Affordable Care Act and a
few things tied in with covid stimulus.
Not that much has actually been done yet as
far as health care goes.
So consider that disconnect right now.
Joe Biden's approval rating is high because
of his handling of covid and the economic
stimulus.
And yet zero Republicans, not few zero Republicans
voted for that very same covid stimulus.
That is part of why Joe Biden is popular,
even with a relatively high number of Republicans.
Now, on the flip side, Joe Biden is not at
50 percent approval on two major issues, gun
policy and immigration.
This is super important because these aren't
two issues on which Joe Biden has just naturally
struggled to build approval.
Those two issues, gun safety and immigration,
are the issues that Republicans have chosen
to attack Joe Biden over.
This means that the Republican counter narratives,
the right wing media, counter narratives do
work.
They do influence people's thinking and people's
opinions and beliefs almost from day one.
I mean that literally day one, I think it
was day five of the Biden presidency, Republicans
and Peter Doocy from Fox News and others started
the counternarrative on immigration.
The border is chaos.
There's kids in cages.
There's kids separated from their parents.
All of the things they didn't care about when
Trump was president.
And it has worked.
It has worked to build the belief that there's
a crisis on immigration and that at least
to some degree, it's Joe Biden's fault.
There were I think it was back in June, 28
percent of Americans believe there was an
immigration crisis.
Now it's 48 percent.
Not much has actually changed other than Republicans
have been hammering this issue.
Second issue on which Joe Biden is not doing
well is gun control.
Biden has done almost nothing on gun control.
Understand that after that recent string of
mass shootings, Joe Biden did announce he
was going to be going after the government
will go after ghost guns a little more and
some very tame, like very, very minor gun
safety issues, some of which may not even
lead to anything because they were Biden saying,
please study this and tell me what to do.
So we need to understand that when you and
I start to see these narratives pop up on
Fox News and Newsmax and Lindsey Graham is
talking about it and whatever we know, they're
fabricated out of thin air.
And we know there's often nothing to them,
but they work and they can be a drag on presidential
approval.
Now, in terms of Joe Biden's 63 percent approval
overall, yeah, to some degree, the American
people are realizing that some things are
going well.
Republicans have been complaining that Joe
Biden's tweeting is too boring and too conventional.
That's a sign they don't have much to complain
about.
We covered that segment on Fox News last week,
which I called Is the economy doing too well
under Biden?
And that's when, you know, things are going
OK economically.
And it's pushing Joe Biden's approval up beyond
where Trump ever was during his presidency.
Remember Trump never achieving 50 percent
approval even once during his presidency.
Joe Biden was at one now at 63.
That's good.
But we have to understand that whatever they
can get purchase on, traction on.
And right now that's guns and immigration.
They will use it to try to win in 2022.
And we simply have to be ready
for it.